yuval harari
in his book sapiens theorizes that
language evolved in humans
as a consequence of thought and
imagination
not principally as a form of
communication
your own work in independent theory
suggests a clear link between cognition
and language any thoughts on the notion
that language evolved
as an introspective tool first
well this this is not a question of
speculation
but of scientific research
so how do you proceed to answer the
question
well do you want to know how some system
evolved
the first thing you have to ask is what
is the nature of the system
it's pointless to ask how
say complex cells
evolve without knowing the nature of a
complex cell
that's truism study of evolution begins
with
understanding the phenotype so what's
the nature of language we have to begin
with that
speculation about how it evolved is
completely idle
unless it's based on an understanding of
the system that evolved
so we take a look at the system that
evolved and i think we find
pretty convincing if not overwhelming
evidence
that its nature its design if you like
to call it that without
any implications about designers just
the technical notion of design
its structure nature is
as fundamentally a system of thought
it turns out that there are for example
conflicts in the nature of language
between
computational efficiency being a
computationally perfect instrument
object
and communicative efficiency use for
utility for thought
every case that we know of communicative
efficiency is sacrificed
it's just not an issue so it seems that
language is based on
concepts of computational efficiency
what mother nature would do if she was
trying
to find the simplest computational
process
which would yield the basic structure of
language
what we find is case after case
it picks nature picks the solution which
yields
thought doesn't care about whether it
harms communication or not
uh we also find that the part that
language basic language is essentially
bifurcated there's an internal
system which effectively
generates thoughts and there's a mode of
externalizing it taking what's internal
and turning it into some sensory motor
output typically sound the
could be sign could even be touch
can't be smelled because we don't have
refined enough
sense of smell but the externalization
is just to
some sensory motor system well there's
by now
[Music]
quite extensive evidence that the
externalization system
does not enter into the functioning
of the internal system could run through
some of the evidence but
i think it's quite convincing so
and furthermore the externalization
system
seems to be ancillary to language in
other respects not only does it not
enter into the functioning of the mode
of
construction of expressions which are
expressions of thought
but it also has huge numbers of
it also seems to be the locus of
the apparent diversity and complexity
and mutability of language
and in fact if you think about it the
externalization system
is not strictly speaking part of
language
the externalization system is by its
nature
an amalgam of whatever the internal
system is
and the nature of the sensory motor
system
in which it's being expressed
and the sensory motor systems are
totally independent of language
they existed long before language
emerged they haven't been affected by
the appearance of language and other
organisms
like say apes and pretty much share
the sensory motor system but have not
even the basic rudiments of language so
it seems to be
systems that are kind of peripheral to
an external to language and those are of
course
the systems used for communication so
when we
put all this together it turns out that
very strong reason to believe that
language evolved
as a a system of
computation which generates
thoughts and then tacked onto it
are modes of uh
externalize it in some sensory mode
motor medium
if that's the case then language did not
evolve as an instrument of communication
but that's the kind of thinking that has
to go on
maybe you can question the steps but
it's
clear that to study to begin with
we're not going to learn about the
evolution of any system
except to the extent that we understand
the nature of that system that's general
for language
or anything else